hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my first preview for a Walking
Dead Season six we finally have a little
bit of footage from the set the cast was
at the Saturn Awards this past weekend
talking a little bit about what's gonna
be going on the only thing we don't have
yet is an official trailer they usually
wait till the comic-con panel to show
that off what I'm gonna do is play this
short clip from the set of Episode one
is just you know Michael Cudlitz walking
around talking to people they don't
answer a whole lot of big questions but
there are some important things going on
in the background that I'm gonna use to
do a breakdown so just be sure to look
around in the frame what's what the cast
is doing hey guys it's Mike Cudlitz here
inside of The Walking Dead Season six
Episode one huge huge episode it's
amazing come on with me
we're gonna go talk to some of the cast
what are you most excited about coming
back Jordan we ended on a really
compelling note so I'm excited to get to
get going I hope that we find out a lot
more about these rules we things can
have them there we had no idea we're
here on set with Lennie James who is
back with us Morgan what's it like to be
back it's a little surreal I'm not gonna
lie to you
it's a little like I've been here
forever and I've never been here
got pretty epic with the flip the stick
or we're gonna maybe find out a little
bit more about that storyline do we not
know I think I know but I'm not sure go
see if we can sneak up on some other
people and they eavesdrop on what's
going on hey I
okay so what's it like being back in
territory it's so funny like as soon as
you've set it up to every face you feel
like you were just here as soon as
you've sweated and had three cups of
coffee you're like okay you had a moment
you can talk directly to the fans that's
a lot of pressure 30 million people um
that I appreciate you guys and that we
all love you and that we're doing this
for you the bumps produces the toenails
that I'm sure I don't have anymore after
wearing these shoes and we're happy that
we have you and your support we're here
with tonigh and we're underneath the
truck to escape the heat of the day
what's it like to be back you know it's
family good good to see you I mean she's
so cool so much I hate to be back you
excited you're back Norman they're
calling us back descend they're gonna
yell at us before I shoot and later
thank you sir
not being on the coloreds yeah now even
kiss my Norman Reedus on my privates the
common man said ready ready ready just
wanted to thank you for showing up and
spending the day with us we're having a
blast season six is gonna be phenomenal
the first episode is gonna blow your
mind
thank you
so really the biggest thing about this
you know not Norman Reedus walking
around kissing everyone is Morgan Morgan
is gonna be big when the show comes back
Lennie James is always a lot of fun but
he's still the lead actor on another
show called critical it's only 13
episodes of season so if he gets renewed
I don't I don't think I'll have any
problems bouncing back and forth between
Walking Dead assuming that at some point
this season he's going to leave the cast
hopefully he doesn't die I'd love to see
him stick around and it would be great
if he stuck around all the way through
season 7 it's just that I don't think
this other show is gonna cause problems
with that look if he left the show it
wouldn't be because of scheduling
problems I think they always had the
intention to bringing him back it's just
that you know before last season when we
saw him a couple times there were really
bad scheduling problems like he had a
bunch of other stuff he was doing some
of that got cancelled so naturally he
was like oh hey I'm available why don't
why don't you bring me back to the
walking dead so Scott Campbell was like
hell yeah I'll bring you back they have
released some key art for episode 1 is
this a big poster with Morgan and brick
front and center it gives you a pretty
good idea of what the dynamic is gonna
be between them it's like you know on
one side you have save zone people then
you have the survivors on the other in
between them is crazy Rick in Jedi
Morgan it's not like there's gonna be a
line drawn in the sand or anything like
that it seems like what they want you to
think is that Morgan is gonna be more
sympathetic with the SafeZone people
than he is with the survivors who her
way more hardcore during that clip when
he said he had some ideas about what was
going on with the staff
he probably just started using it as a
non-lethal way to deal with people like
the Wolves at the end of the last season
which he totally should have killed
there's always like the external
conflicts you have on the show you know
them fighting the governor fighting the
walkers but then you have the internal
conflicts underneath that fights between
members inside the group so the big
fight this year or at least when the
season picks up is gonna be Morgan's
philosophy versus Rick's philosophy the
exact same thing went on inside Michonne
like completely localized to her
character where she started out being
super hardcore they got to the safe zone
she hung her katana up and started being
sheriff Michonne it was like she was
trying to leave behind her violent past
she's like I don't need this anymore cut
to the end of the season where she takes
it back down where she's like okay yeah
maybe I do need it I think she's just
the balance between Rick and Morgan's
philosophy so either they find some sort
of internal
equilibrium or the [ __ ] is gonna hit the
fan and it's gonna tear the group apart
that's usually what you see happen with
like Rick's character where he sees
something else going on like some other
conflict and it makes him think about
what he's doing where he's like oh my
god I'm Way too crazy now he doesn't
quite reach that point though you know
people were making jokes about how he
basically turned into Shane who is now
officially The Punisher by the way that
that's a pretty big deal but I don't
think that Rick is Shane that's just a
funny way to think about how short he's
gotten with situations where he's just
like nope not having it gonna shut this
down old Rick would have probably had
several conversations with Pete before
it came to blows Rick right now just has
no more time for [ __ ] if you do want
to read along in the comic book with
season 6 episode 1 we'll pick up right
around where vol 14 no way out picks up
so you can read ahead if you want or
don't read it either way they are doing
more stuff from the comics but remember
it's still an adaptation and a lot of
the characters have been changed to fit
with the cast that they have like
Douglas Munro in the comics is this
female leader of the safe zone so
they've gender been a few characters
then you have people like Daryl who
aren't in the comics at all but we will
be seeing storylines from that comic and
we'll be seeing locations that they
visit so if you want to know what some
of those are and you don't care about
potential spoilers just read ahead in
the comic but back to the video so look
around what's going on in the background
it looks like they're barricading the
road with more stuff Michonne is sitting
under this 18-wheeler I don't know if
that belongs to the wolves or if it's
just another one they found and they're
using it to barricade the road with
extra stuff but it looks like they're
expecting the wolves to come and they're
just preparing for it or it could just
be routine maintenance just looking at
it this looks like new construction
though it's not like they're rebuilding
walls too bad they don't have an
engineer anymore say little silent
prayer for Dee's husband they do a
pretty good job of changing the dynamic
on the show like every half season so
expect this first half to feel very
different from the second half of season
5 but I don't think they're gonna do a
repeat of season 5 episode 1 where they
blew up terminus in that first episode
if they do repeat anything I'm really
hoping to see some more Rambo Carol
Sasha's kind of taken that role on
herself she's kind of like comic book
Andrea sitting up in the tower she's got
the assault rifle so if anyone's gonna
be mowing down any walkers it's probably
gonna be her right now though Carol
is still my favorite character she is
like the Colossus of the group which is
why it's so funny that she dresses like
a housewife it's all an act you know
she's just hiding behind those cookies
those very awesome scary cookies here's
my question for you guys after the
events of the finale who's your favorite
character on the show right now it like
what are you hoping to see from them in
the first episode care will go crazy
Sasha Moe the [ __ ] out of some people
there aren't a whole lot of wolves like
actual human wolves most of the bodies
that they have are all Walker's like
there's like a couple wolves controlling
all them they spent a ton of money
building Daryl's custom bike so I'm
hoping they don't trash that in the
first episode either the only problem
with having so many awesome main
characters is that a lot of the lesser
characters kind of get put by the
wayside when you have big episodes and
they're all in it together
so like Karla needed very interesting
dynamic but they might not get featured
quite as much just because so much is
going on in this first episode I really
do expect a lot from Edith's character
she's like one of the most fascinating
young female characters that we've seen
on the show Lizzie Miko were a lot of
fun but they were like way way younger
you know by having like a slightly older
teenage girl I think they can have
someone that will challenge Carl but
someone that he can also learn a lot
from Beth was starting to get there but
she was almost like this precious flower
growing in the weeds so naturally all
the weeds were gonna choke her out at
some point one of my other favorite new
safestone characters is Aaron like the
Aaron Daryl dynamic Aaron just seems
like a really awesome dude it seems like
he knows his [ __ ] just as well as Daryl
I didn't enjoy like the really awkward
dinner scenes with with his boyfriend
quite as much just just when Daryl and
Aaron are off in the wilderness together
just because Daryl hates talking so much
and Aaron kind of gets that even though
even though he presses him all the time
there's so many odd pairings on the show
you have Karlin eated you have Rick and
Morgan you have Daryl and Carol I don't
really get into shipping or anything
like that really hardcore but it's just
it's so funny when you see those
characters together when you see those
odd pairings I feel like whenever there
isn't a whole lot of action on screen
that that's what's most fun about the
show so just a reminder about the
comic-con panel that's gonna be on
Friday I'm gonna do like a big Comic Con
preview where I talk about like when
everything is gonna be happening they'll
drop the trailer but it's gonna be two
hours because it's gonna bring out the
entire cast of fear The Walking Dead too
so we'll probably learn a lot about that
show when we do get a little bit closer
like it
especially right around comic-con I'll
start doing Q&A videos for The Walking
Dead again - and the weekly giveaway
will start up again in fact I'll go
ahead and start it right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner whenever I post my
next Walking Dead video should be by
next week I've got a couple other videos
I'm working out for the weekend you can
find updates for that stuff on on
Twitter and Facebook links in the
description if you don't know where to
find those so time to start preparing
yourself for fear of The Walking Dead in
season 6 well you guys wait for my next
video you can click here for my fear The
Walking Dead trailer video and you can
click here for my season six predictions
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight